what started with a virus so small your
eyes couldn't see it this is about
providing future for humanity the
commission has decided to find google
4.34 billion
[Music]
is euros man on the moon moment we are
innovating here and we hope that you
like it
[Music]
welcome to europe calling the first in a
series of podcasts brought to you by the
european commission looking at the
politics and policies of the union today
and of course political life just like
daily life remains
dominated by covid our main guest for
this pilot edition is health
commissioner stella kiriakides who's
been at the front line of europe's fight
against the pandemic
we'll be discussing the commission's new
therapeutics strategy a proposal
announced just today
we'll be talking to journalists and
citizens across the eu putting their
points and questions direct to
miscarriages
including on mental health issues which
is one of her areas of expertise
and if thumping rock with a heart and a
message is your thing and it's certainly
ours
stay with us as we present belgium's
banging souls
direct from the attic recording studio
i'm stephen jones i'm paul anderson
and running the technicals tebow jama
first up some perspectives on the
situation from different parts of europe
italy has been among the hardest hit
countries in the world
at the outbreak of the pandemic it was
europe's epicenter
alessandra quatrochi is head of video
news for the italian news agency asca
news
and here's her overview of how italy is
managing now
the refrain that i hear everywhere is we
should have done things better
why are we so behind in a vaccination
effort
the european union should have managed
better the contracts with the
pharmaceutical houses
italy should have done better for itself
okay that's the past but we're also
looking to the future
and we shouldn't forget that in the 750
billion euro
eu recovery plan italy is among the
member states that stands to benefit the
most
what i want to know is what are italians
saying about how their share of the
funding should be used
generally speaking people think that it
should be used
to improve the health sectors and also
to help small and medium enterprises and
then there is a general
thinking that it should be used to
improve the
technology sector and to modernize italy
and paul she has one issue especially
important to her that she's keen to
raise directly with the commissioner
i think that it's wonderful for the
first time to see so many women
in power in europe and this pandemic
showed us that there is need
of a combined effort on the part of the
european countries
to do more when there is need of care in
the family
it is all done by women that's
alessandra quattrocchi from asca news
in italy and now over to poland with
mateos mazzini who's a writer for the
polish magazine politica
what's his take on the situation there
generally speaking the mood is rather
negative
we see the the coalition losing support
we see
tensions within the government well when
things aren't going quite so well at
national level there's a tendency to
want to shift the blame elsewhere i
wonder if that's happening in poland
the general public doesn't really see
brussels as the culprit
of that situation there might be
occasional propaganda talk
about the efficiency of the vaccine
itself especially on the the astrazeneca
vaccine but that's not unique to poland
brussels
is not really being blamed for it there
were attempts to to do that but they
uh failed one of for me one of the
interesting features of poland is the
degree to which
its economy is based almost entirely on
small to medium-sized
enterprises and what i would like to
know is how they've fared in the past
year
this is the main line of contention and
dissatisfaction
every day you turn on the news every day
you open up a newspaper
you read testimonies of people running
restaurants or
gyms or swimming pools saying it's been
the fifth six
seven months that we have had no income
and we received zero money
there's a lot of civil disobedience on
behalf of
uh entrepreneurs in poland so now an
opportunity for mateos has for
alessandra
to raise a point directly with the
commissioner what would be his
issue well i'm particularly curious if
anyone in brussels
has a plan of helping out public
healthcare systems for what comes after
the pandemic
we tend to hear chatter that the polish
healthcare system is on the brink of
collapse
but i fear that the worst is yet to come
good afternoon stella kiriakids european
commissioner for health and food safety
hello good afternoon many thanks indeed
for uh joining us here you've been
listening to our interviews just now
with journalists in poland
and italy and in particular the question
that they've wanted to put to you
what's your response first of all to
matteo in poland on potential support
from the european union for healthcare
services
well thank you very much for that
question yes i would say that
we have been addressing this and this is
part of the proposals that we have put
forward for are you
a new european health union to have more
resilient health care systems
and also part of the proposals in our eu
for health program an ambitious program
with a budget
of over 5 billion so in the future not
only for this crisis but for future
crisis health systems
are more resilient and better prepared
commissioner stephen jones here
what's your response to alessandra's
point about the disproportionate burden
carried by women during the pandemic
women are those that are represented the
most in the care sector
in terms also of the healthcare
frontline workers in many areas and of
course
it is something that we are addressing
as the eu also in our
equality strategy in order to support
those who have been most affected by
covet 19.
commissioner the european commission
today has unveiled its therapeutic
strategy
what is it and how will member states
stand to benefit
research and development of therapeutics
for covet 19 is crucial
and we need to have a response to this
we're also
learning this virus will probably be
amongst us
uh even though vaccination rates are
going up that
uh citizens people are falling ill with
covet 19
and that many of them then describe that
they have long-term symptoms so what
we're
here aiming to do is to pull together
the very valuable research the
many clinical trials the experience and
expertise in the area of therapeutics
going on across europe
let's move now to some questions for you
commissioner from europeans who want to
ask about various
aspects of this crisis first to anitra
in riga
in latvia hello
and the question that i would like to
ask is
as we all know the rate of vaccination
has differed massively
across member states in europe the
effectiveness of vaccination campaigns
has also been very
viable is it real or a fantasy to reach
the 70
target by july you're absolutely right
uh we face bottlenecks in supply and
production
uh by working closely with companies uh
the production
in new capacity in europe has increased
significantly
deliveries have increased significantly
now in quarter two
vaccination programs are rolling out
with member states
and the target vaccination of seventy
percent of the other
population by the middle uh or by end
the middle or end of july
is ambitious but it is also feasible
next a question from katja in kiel in
germany hi
there i have a question to ask with
regards to
vaccine supplies to poorer countries who
takes care of that and is there enough
being done
to a supply them and track the supplies
as well because i think
not only western countries need to be
healthy
in order to keep global economy running
but we need
the eastern or poorer countries as well
global pandemics
require global solutions and this is the
only way we're going to be able to move
forward
be working very closely from day one
with who
with other organizations because we when
we say no one is safe until everyone is
safe this mustn't just be a phrase it
must be something that we actually
believe in and we do as the eu
thank you very much our third question
is in the form of an email from fiona
from waterford in ireland and she writes
if there is a further covid surge
surely the best step to take would be to
block travel between countries anywhere
in the eu
she feels strongly about this she says
because ireland on the westernmost edge
of the european union
shouldn't have had the problem it has
had first of all
we're all aware that the measures that
are taken by member states
are taken at national level of course
different countries have their different
epidemiological situations
a fundamental principle of the eu
is the freedom of movement and of travel
and this is why we have put forward
the proposal for the digital green
certificate
and we hope that this will move forward
in june
in order to find a coordinated approach
that will enable us to open up
travel and economies of movement within
the eu safely
and finally to margarita who's from
italy thank you for the chance to ask a
question
commissioner may ask you about the live
entertainment sector
and in particular about cultural
festivals
this is the second summer of
restrictions and cancellations
how can do you help this sector to
recover
cultural events have been heavily
impacted on because
social distancing has been part of
of the non-pharmaceutical measures that
we need to have in place
but as we move forward with vaccinations
increasing
keeping to our measures i am cautiously
optimistic that we will be able to see
many of these sectors reopening
many thanks to everyone who's put
questions to commissioner kiryakires and
to you commissioner
please stay with us still
now the european medicines agency the
ema
has played a pivotal role in the
management of the pandemic
that role is to promote the development
of medicines and vaccines
and to evaluate and authorize them for
release in the market joining us from
the agency's headquarters in
amsterdam is noel wathian the ema's
deputy executive director mr watian
thanks for joining us here on
europe calling it's a pleasure what has
the agency learned from this pandemic
for the better management of future ones
i can give you some examples we
introduced the concept of
so-called rapid scientific advice and
this is something
that we can also use for any future
public health
emergencies in terms of midterm
lessons learned uh one has to think
about
reinforcing the uh the preparedness the
crisis preparation and the crisis
response
at the level of the eu what's your
response to the sometimes
widespread vaccine hesitation and even
vaccine rejection
we have to make sure that we have high
quality
scientific expertise and you have to
reassure the public
about that a second element is
transparency
it is important that people know how
these vaccines are being assessed
where does the ema stand right now on
the authorization of the russian vaccine
sputnik 5 and the chinese vaccines
well it is important to emphasize that
all
vaccines or all applications that are
being made at the level of ema
are treated in exactly the same way for
sputnik we are in the process of a
rolling review
which is i would say the penultimate
phase before
the an application for conditional
marketing organizations in terms of the
chinese vaccine primarily the xenovac
vaccine
here we are at a little earlier stage i
would say we're also in dialogue
but we have not yet started the rolling
review which means
that the data package is not yet that
substantial
what's your wider reflection on europe's
response to covet
i think we have been confronted with
quite a historic scientific
achievement because within less than one
year
following the announcement of the uh of
the pandemic situation
we were able to join efforts and to make
sure
uh that we have vaccines available as
quickly as possible so that we can
protect
public health from the european
medicines agency
thank you for joining us commissioner
kiryakidis thanks for still being with
us
let's look back on the difficulties the
eu faced with the vaccine rollout
how would you respond to critics who say
the commission simply got it wrong
i would say to them that we need to
see where we are now yes there were
challenges
in the supply and in the delivery and
the production of vaccines at the
beginning of this year
but now the vaccination deliveries are
increasing they're more predictable and
more and more citizens are being
vaccinated
every day we have safe and effective
vaccines across the european
union and countries whether they were
big or small member states
have had equal access with citizens
being vaccinated at the same time
this for myself and for all of us is
really
european solidarity in action some
member states have gone their own way in
terms of vaccine procurements
how helpful or not has that been to
europe's overall response
some member states may have moved
forward with vaccines that were not in
our portfolio
and approved by the european medicines
agency but
i think that what we can say here is the
importance of the coordination
and the strength of solidarity and unity
with member states and this has really
been from the beginning
key in in all the areas i'd like to turn
now to mental health which i know is an
area of expertise for you personally
as a clinical psychologist specializing
in children and adolescents
what has struck you most forcefully over
the past 15 months or so about the
impact of cobit on people's mental
health
everything has struck me um i think that
we've been concentrating and we need to
concentrate it on the physical side of
of the repercussions of covet 19. we
have seen
here because of the pandemic huge
suffering
loss of lives in families it has changed
our world it has changed our lives
children not attending school the
greatest toll on the most vulnerable
the elderly being isolated for myself
but for us as a commission mental health
is a priority
we are going to be doing everything
possible to support member states
and at the moment we're working on this
through the health policy platform
but we're going to be working in order
to
ensure that member states have the
support they need to increase
the provision of mental health services
finally commissioner kiri kiddies
some quick questions demanding quick
answers
the covert recovery program 750 billion
euros what are europe's top priorities
to boost and support member states to
help them recover from the pandemic
greener and more sustainable economies
what's the key lesson for you
in dealing with future pandemics the
strength of solidarity
the importance of coordination the
importance of unity with member states
and a european health union so that we
face
future health crisis together as a union
the kovacs program to get vaccines to
less developed parts of the world
we need global solutions we have had
challenges
but this is something that is a top
priority for us with team europe and we
will continue to support
in every way possible stella kiriakidis
european commissioner for health
and food safety thank you very much now
stephen let me put this question to you
if you were to ask europeans what
they're most looking forward to
doing again after pandemic restrictions
begin to ease a bit
how high would music gigs and festivals
be on their list
good question paul the music sector has
been pretty much stopped dead in its
tracks by kobit 19
and it's unclear when even if it will
fully recover
most affected are clearly the performers
themselves
performers like ludwig pasha and gail
mavis
founding members of the belgian rock
trio the banging souls
whose music you're listening to right
now
[Music]
well ludwig and gael are in a recording
studio in the attic of a house in namur
just
south of brussels first let me ask you
both about the effect
prolonged lockdown has had on you at the
beginning we thought that
we would get over it and that in a few
months we would quickly
be able to get our life back so we tried
to
write new songs stay in touch with our
fans we did concerts on facebook but
with no visibility no purpose and uh
little income we quickly lose our faith
and today it's been over a year that we
are still unmute
we're waiting for like a signal but we
don't have any
so uh we don't keep the faith we
lose faith in public power in addition
to losing a job we will have
lost family friends freedom and
self-esteem
it is a hell of a battle that we are
fighting now and i hope we'll get
through this together when you get back
to performing publicly and making music
in the coming
months and years are you thinking of new
themes for songs you're thinking of new
ways of making music
we'll never stop doing music but how can
we
decently leave today how can we be
heard and seen the industry uh of music
has changed
fundamentally everything is is done to
to encourage us to to be alone to be
launched
yes and to get on any platforms for less
than one euro cent per stream and
we can't be happy or in peace with that
so
i think that today the independent
artist has to
we have to get closer to to to the
people maybe create
download platforms that will work fairly
that will be a change yes a download
platform
fairly download platform we can compete
with those big platforms
and if venues or festivals remain closed
we can't exist
it's quite a depressing and sad picture
that you paint there particularly when
you look at it
in the context of live music being the
lifeblood for musicians
live music is everything for brands when
we create a song
uh the purpose is to bring it on stage
we can see directly the reactions of the
people
and a band needs to get on stage it
needs to play to achieve
you talked a little bit earlier about
streaming platforms what do you think
europe can do to help artists succeed
in 2020 spotify
increased their their income by 25
percent
and do we get money for that no we we
can't
even buy us a year a b at the end of the
month
people don't realize that they you have
a plenty
of artists on these platforms everybody
can listen to anybody but
only the big stars get the money and
that's not fair
in united kingdom for example a
commission of inquiry
has been conducted by the government to
in order to properly redistribute the
income to the
the actor of popular culture and i hope
that
europe will follow and i hope that you
will defend artists who are struggling
now
ludwig pancha gail from the banging
souls thank you very much for joining us
this has been europe calling our thanks
to commissioner kiryakiris and to all
our other guests
we'll be back keep an eye on the europe
calling podcast page
for news on future editions from me paul
anderson
me stephen jones and our sound engineer
tibo jamal
thank you for listening
[Music]
cuz
[Music]
what started with a virus so small your
eyes couldn't see it this is about
providing a future for humanity the
commission has decided to find google
4.34 billion euros
this is europe's man on the moon moment
we are innovating here and we hope that
you like it
[Applause]
[Music]
europe